a rescue George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family don't move
a muscle
are you crazy don't move very funny you
and I laughing at your joke new guy you
know about he cry you can get up now and
check your diaper come on your message
about George you okay George it's okay
isn't mirrors he considerably bigger no
he's definitely bigger need to find
someone who knows exactly what the hell
this thing is
I found her no that's a lie technically
she found us what's happening to my
friend are you familiar with genetic
editing changes will be incredibly
unpredictable increased strength George
speed agility
bills and chains that came run Where's
George I need to see him he is dangerous
I think it's time for me to turn the man
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project rampage works
another one of your little science
experiments running around what do you
mean
of course the wolf flies
this time we throw everything we can at
these things and get people the hell out
of that city let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't fight it
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people right I do know that yeah
but that's not fun
George okay ready to do this buddy
you
you